-You know our next guest
from her work on
"Saturday Night Live,"
which airs this Saturday
on NBC and Peacock,
with host Brendan Gleeson.
Please welcome to the
show Sarah Sherman, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I am so happy
you're here, Sarah.
-I'm happy to be here, too.
-So, you're back in New York
to start a second season.
I know you did stand-up
over the summer.
Was it different doing stand-up
after a year on "SNL"?
-Yeah, because, like,
people came to my stand-up shows
being like, "Oh, there's, like,
the girl with brown hair
from 'SNL.'
I'm gonna see her do
tame, normal, polite stand-up."
And they were not prepared for
very rude, scary stand-up.
-Yeah.
-I'm, like, up there, like,
snorting like
a warthog, screaming.
-So we see the tamest version
of you on "SNL."
-I think so, yeah.
-You have described
your style of comedy as
"body horror comedy."
-Yeah.
-Which is a lovely genre
that I didn't even know existed.
-Yeah, and it shouldn't.
It's very gross.
And it's disgusting,
and I should behave.
-But the interesting thing
about body horror comedy is,
it would never occur to me that
Lorne Michaels would think,
"That's what we need
on the show."
Now, it's turned out to be
a really nice fit,
but when you were
doing that style of comedy,
did you ever think to yourself,
"Oh, man, once 'SNL' sees this,
I'm gonna be right
in that cast"?
-I definitely did not think that
doing stand-up shows
where I was, like,
screaming, like "Aaaah!"
and, like -- You know,
that's what it's like, the show.
You guys are laughing.
You love it.
And I would, like,
do stand-up shows where
I'm, like, screaming, and then
showing videos of, like,
a papier-mâché butthole
with, like,
Hamburger Helper meat
coming out of it.
[ Audience groans ]
And, like -- Oh, you think
that's gross? Really?
Have you seen
the gas prices lately?
They're disgusting.
-You're very political.
You've always been
very political.
-Absolutely, Seth.
But, like, you know,
doing shows like that,
I never would have thought
that that would be
necessarily a
job application for "SNL."
-It has -- I think one of
the most unique things about
your first year is,
there were things that
you did on the show
that I don't think anyone
before would ever occur to them.
You did a wonderful sketch
called "Meatballs"
where you had a body
where you had singing meatballs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The wonderful Oscar Isaac played
one of the singing meatballs.
This is a sense of --
I guess that's where --
Is that where Oscar's head was?
-Yeah, his little head
went in there.
-And he was on the show when
I was talking to him about it,
and, you know, he gets
approached all the time
about "Meatballs," maybe more
than anything else he's done.
-Are you for real?
-He said it's really been a nice
piece of feedback for him,
and it doesn't really bump
against any of his other work,
his "Meatball" work.
-That's hilarious.
"Oh, Oscar Isaac, you were great
in 'Star Wars' or whatever,
but loved you as a meatball."
-You also had a wonderful sketch
where you played Chucky.
This is really
the impressive thing,
because this is --
They CGI'd your face onto this.
But just to get a sense of
how many people have to work
to get Chucky -- I mean,
that's a three-team puppeteer.
-Can you believe this?
Like, a dumb idea like,
"Hey, what if my real head
was a on a puppet Chucky body?
Can you guys, like, go above
and beyond to make this happen?"
Like, literally
all these puppeteers --
Monkey Boys, shout-out.
They're the name of
the puppeteers.
And, like, they all have to get
keyed out of this, like, scene,
because they're, like,
there making the puppet move,
and they all have to get,
like, erased in the edit.
Like, that's amazing.
-I mean, it is the
greatest thing about "SNL,"
which is dumb ideas
are then executed by --
But, no, genuinely, I --
Where just you have a dumb idea
in the middle of the night,
and then professionals
have to execute it.
And every time it happens,
you just feel
so incredibly grateful.
-It's, like, amazing.
I was like,
"I can't believe, like,
the best artists
in the world are, like,
actively gluing a meatball
into my armpit
that is gonna eventually have
Charli XCX's
singing face on it."
Like, it's just --
Like, it's amazing.
-You -- Because you are
someone who --
Because of the style of the
show you were doing,
you were doing
a ton of your own makeup.
And because
you were also doing videos,
a lot of special effects --
I mean, you explained
your papier-mâché butthole,
which we all, I think,
are huge fans of.
-Sorry about that.
-But this is a -- What --
So, you know what
I'm about to show you.
This is a meat suit?
-Yeah, it's a meat suit.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-I do want to prepare people.
Yeah, you know what?
Maybe I'm not going to prepare.
-Relax.
-Just take a look.
I mean, it's real. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is -- this is --
I mean, this is D.I.Y.
This is all -- And that --
Now, that does look to me
like actual meat.
-And, Seth,
I hate to break it to you,
but it truly is actual meat.
Well, 'cause I was, like --
When I was living in Chicago,
I'm like, "I have 30 bucks.
How do I make it look like
I've got no skin?"
-Yes.
-So, of course, what do I do?
I superglued prosciutto
and bacon to my face.
And then the teeth are just,
like, press-on nails.
And the eyeballs are
Ping-Pong balls, of course.
-Yeah.
-But I was like, "How do I make
it look like I'm covered --
like I'm just gore
and I have no skin?"
So I was like, "I'll just glue a
bunch of raw meat to me."
And then, now that I, like,
work in, like,
professional, fancy,
adult settings,
people are like,
"Yeah, you don't have to, like,
use real raw meat to do that.
You can just absolutely
not do that."
And that stank badly.
-I do -- I just do like that
you were living in Chicago
and the solution was meat.
Seems very, like, Chicago.
-Totally.
-And everything in Chicago,
a lot of solutions are just,
"Go get prosciutto."
You -- I'm wondering how --
You know, I think one of the
coolest things about "SNL" is,
it's a show that your parents
know when you get the job.
Are they happy about
this chapter in your life?
-It's like the best thing
that's ever happened to them.
It's like my Bat Mitzvah
all over again.
Like, I think they got a little
worried when they saw, like,
the comedy that I was doing was
like, you know, crazy.
I'm popping huge pimples
on my face,
and, like, cottage cheese
is squirting out of them.
Like, I think they were
a little nervous.
And then once, like,
I got on "SNL," they're like,
"I guess we're
not nervous anymore?"
-Where were you
when you got the call?
-Well, actually, funny enough --
I swear to God --
I was at home on Long Island,
with my parents and my grandma,
eating spaghetti and meatballs
when I got the call
that I got "SNL."
And then, little did I know,
meatballs was gonna factor
hugely into my life.
-I thought -- I like the idea
that you got the call,
and think, "Oh, my God.
What am I gonna do for
my first sketch?"
And then, as a meatball rose
towards your mouth...
-Well, what's so great
about "SNL," is, like,
when I got the job,
I was like, "Oh, God,
what am I going to do
on the show?"
Like, "The only impression
I can do is, like,
Stewie Griffin or something."
From "Family Guy."
Hilarious little guy.
Little baby, big head. Whatever.
I was like,
"What am I gonna do?"
And then, so, I was
a little nervous for a second,
and then all the writers are,
like, so amazing.
Like, there's this writer,
Dan Bulla,
who called me, and he was like,
"I have an idea for you.
You do, like,
body horror comedy.
What if you, like,
were covered in meatballs?"
And I was like...
[ Gasps ]
..."Everything's gonna be okay!
Oh, my God! This is amazing!"
-I would say
it's more than okay.
And I'm so happy you're here.
It has just been a delight to
watch you on "SNL."
And I'm especially --
[ Cheers and applause ]
especially grateful to have you
here with us today.
-Cool. Thanks for having me.
-You guys, that's Sarah Sherman.
"SNL" airs this Saturday
on NBC and Peacock
with host Brendan Gleeson
and musical guest Willow.
We'll be back with more
"Late Night."